[Musique]
sujet comme je les dis ô combien
intéressant donc on va voir un peu avec
les attaques venant ici comment ils
envisagent comment il
il voit la vidéo dans l'enseignement ont
peut-être commencé en euros gars ont vu
qu'il est tout seul je ne sais pas c'est
quelqu'un qui veut commencer à
introduire le sujet valentine ou l'ofrou
note comme vous voulez il faut se lancer
la vidéo
moi j'ai une question s'est fait
devancer par une session en fait c'est
un personnage je suis pas enseignante et
je me dis escure en tant que prof ceux
qui s'y sont enseignants ou s'imaginer
enseignants est ce que ça vous est déjà
arrivé où vous pensez qu'on classe 2
diffuse auriez peut-être une vidéo de
c'est pas sorcier pour expliquer un
concept scientifique et aux élèves ça
vous semble un truc faisable web etc
selon vous qu'est ce que ça apporte
on se donnera comme coach avait vu que
ce film et c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on garde des traces pour les
interventions de juste chaque fois
prendre le temps de se donner un gros la
justice est possédée non mais parce que
c'est toujours très intéressantes mais
change alors de parler il ya dans les
pronoms micro juste moi je pense que si
j'étais enseignante et que j'avais
expliqué un concept scientifique à mes
enfants et je commence avec une absolue
en fait c'est pas sorcier ce que ça
apporterait en dehors de l'aspect
effectivement un peu ludique un peu
divertissant c'est que ils vont avoir
accès à des objets à des outils à du
matériel que j'ai pas forcément apporté
si c'est par exemple un taux qui demande
énormément de place je vais pas pour
faire la démonstration c'est pas sorcier
vont à faire et donc c'est super cool de
pouvoir montrer aux élèves comment ça se
passe techniquement moi je vois moi j'ai
une chaîne beaucoup je parle d'histoire
de l'art et l'énorme avantage c'est que
quand je fais un montage vidéo est ce
que la vidéo ma porte pour expliquer là
c'est le support visuel c'est de pouvoir
moi dira à cet endroit jeu qui est une
flèche qui fasse un arc de cercle pour
expliquer ce que cette forme représente
dans le tableau et que ça l'a désigné
que ça la met vraiment en exergue et
c'est un support visuel qui peut être je
pense extrêmement utile dans le cadre de
l'enseignement et donc quand je pense à
la vidéo non seulement je pense à ça
après ce que je sais aussi c'est en tant
que vulgarisatrice sais que si je fais
une vidéo
étant donné que aussi sur youtube on a
tombé youtube on va assez vite on essaye
d'insérer des petites blagounettes très
très drôle
les gens ne retiennent pas spécialement
ce qu'on dit en fait ça les intéresse
ils en tirent une idée mais c'est c'est
pas suffisant quand ils sont chez eux à
consommer la vidéo ils retiennent à
cepovett
donc on le sait on assez donc je pense
que davantage de montrer une vidéo dans
une classe avec un enseignant c'est que
l'enseignant il peut parler de la vidéo
ensuite avec ses élèves
il peut se servir du support visuel de
ce qu'il apporte
et ensuite poussé le sujet plus loin
interrogés les élèves pour voir ce
qu'ils ont retenu la vidéo etc
c'est plus une introduction au sujet on
va parler de ça tu balances la vidéo et
après tu l'entends course pour moi bon
en tout cas en ce qui me concerne quand
je pense à mes vidéos et je pense à
l'utilisation qu'un enseignant pourrait
faire de mes vidéos
il ya deux cas de figure que voix soit
effectivement ils l'utilisent en classe
très brièvement pour le support visuel
que ça apporte
mais c'est évident que ne s'arrête pas
juste le fait de montrer la vidéo
pour moi il faut qu'ils aient un travail
après parce que l' avantage quel
enseignant par rapport à nous c'est que
nous on est derrière notre écran on sait
absolument pas la personne qui est
derrière son ordinateur elle par contre
elle peut être en train de faire un jeu
sur son téléphone d'écrire un texto on
ne sait absolument pas ce qui se passe
est en fait ça très bien qu'à une
rétention d'information qui est très
très très très faible on vraiment moi je
sais pour parler avec des gens ils
viennent assez peu en fait s'il regarde
juste une vidéo en passant sur youtube
alors que l'enseignant il est face à ses
élèves et voit la réaction et après pour
moi il peut aussi en parler avec eux il
peut revenir sur les points de
comprendre son éventuel alors que nous
on sait pas on sait qu'on ne voit pas en
mesure pas forcément quand on touche du
doigt le concept très très compliqué on
ne se rend pas forcément compte qu'il
est compliqué et on va peut-être avoir
des trop vite et d'une chose que la
vidéo de l'enseignement elle est
et c'est ça qu'elle apporte en fait elle
apporte le support visuel ou à la porte
moi j'ai déjà eu le cas d'un élève qui
est le mien commentaires sur une vidéo
en me disant c'est notre prof qui nous a
demandé de regarder cette vidéo quand
même rare au début du mal pris nous
allons devoir nommer c'est un plaisir
devant la vidéo
n'empêche ça extrêmement intelligent
comme manière de faire aussi parce que
j'ai fait une partie de mes études dans
des pays anglo-saxons et notamment aux
états unis
ce qu'on nous faisait faire c'est que on
avait énormément de travail le personnel
et après on arrivait en cours et on
avait lu par exemple temps de chapitres
et on débriefait les chapitres écrite le
propre on était dans un échange on
n'était pas juste dans là on était en la
tenue en france de ce qu'on avait lu la
veille et je me suis en fait ce que se
croient pas fait c'est super sympa parce
que les élèves n'ont pas forcément
l'impression de faire de devoir d'en
face ont plus de mater une vidéo et le
lendemain ça permet en fait aux profs de
revenir là dessus et d'approfondir donc
déjà ça se fait en deux temps
ce qui je pense est toujours bien enfin
c'est toujours mieux de revenir de
revenir sur une première fois et ça
permet en plus de pas laisser les lèvres
seul face à un support à sucre en vidéo
ou éventuellement il ya des choses qui
va pas comprendre
et moi je pense que ça c'est une
utilisation en fin de compte j'ai vu ce
commentaire c'est vraiment une situation
très intéressante et je crois qu'il ya
des études scientifiques qui ont été
faites et on a effectivement conclu que
le meilleur mode d'apprentissage c'était
effectivement cette manière un peu
américain c'est dur de faire ça pas mal
de travail personnel
la vesle et le lendemain de revenir
dessus ils ont fait travailler des
panels est la priorité
j'étais à face à ce que la potion de de
faire un truc
voilà donc voila moi si les performances
et moi pas seulement c'est comme ça que
j'envisage la vidéo dans l'enseignement
après je ne suis pas enseignante je suis
potentiellement enseignante en devenir
mais mais c'est moi c'est moi depuis je
fais de la vulgarisation j'ai forcément
réfléchi à escobar au jour des profs
voudrait utiliser mes vidéos et je me
suis dit voilà ça c'est pour moi c'est
vraiment les deux trucs formidables qui
apporte la vidéo sur internet donc
bonjour a tous su baptiste j'ai la
chaîne youtube par leur histoire
je sais également professionnels de
l'éducation nationale en france comme
l'histoire géographie histoire de rester
dans le même thème et suis pas d'accord
avec toi enfin je suis d'accord avec
tout ce qui est classe inversement tout
le système dont tu parles
ça s'appelle la classe inversé c'est
quelque chose qui arrive de plus en plus
en france et s'échauffent que c'est une
bonne chose aussi
mais ce système a montré ses limites
notamment laissé la lève travailler seul
pour ensuite revenir en classe ça pose
quelques problèmes justement par rapport
par rapport au fait que certains ont pas
faire ce travail préliminaire et du coup
si ce travail des libyens dès pas fait
tout le reste est foutu voilà où ses
parents le débat rebondit relaxer mais
du coup je suis pas d'accord avec toi
quand tu te dis que
quand on regarde une vidéo faisait enfin
en tout cas la plupart des gens ne
tiennent pas ça dépend évidemment du
contexte dans lequel on regarde cette
vidéo mais il ya aussi le la façon dont
l'auteur regarder parce que en cours les
élèves sont là parce que doivent le
faire la société leur imposent leurs
parents les imposent ils doivent être la
vie d'avant c'est pareil pour tout le
monde on me dit de faire quelque chose
moi j'ai promis de faire juste parce que
tu l'as dit de le faire c'est pareil les
élèves ou l'ordi d'être là d'apprendre à
apprendre en apprend pour réussir ta vie
alors que youtube c'est différent la
posture différente du quand un élève
qu'importe n'importe qui va sur youtube
il a envie la plupart du temps de
regarder quand c'est par devoir
c'est donc juste sept changements dans
la mentalité je pense sont re voilà
changé énormément de choses sur la façon
dont on appréhende la vidéo parce que on
a envie de la regarder cette vidéo je
clique sur plaît parce que j'ai envie de
regarder juste ça ça je pense que ça
permet de se rappeler de pas mal de
choses et le nom de
on s'est peut-être pas très objectif
mais le nombre d'élèves qui viennent me
voir alors que pour une vidéo que j'ai
sorti même il ya plusieurs mois et au
visage avec mes ses passages dans votre
vidéo ou alors juste là je suis en train
de faire avec mes troisièmes la guerre
froide où j'ai fait une partie d'une
double la vidéo sur la partition de
l'accord et donc qui rentre très bien
dans ce cadre une vidéo qui est sorti il
ya quand même au moins il ya pas mal de
temps à au moins un an voire plus et du
coup je commence à parler de la guerre
froide et la corée puis l'a10 et n'est
pas l'avis de sava corps et vous avez
dit ça ça ouais et alors que je verrai
jamais dit la regardes et tu vois c'est
donc mon nom je compte sur vous que
youtube peut être un parfait complément
à ce que le prof peut apporter
il peut pas remplacer le prof de selon
moi parce que comme si c'est ça aussi tu
l'as dit l'élève n'a pas toujours un
esprit critique et il ya beaucoup de
choses qui se disent sur youtube
beaucoup beaucoup de choses qui sont mal
dit sur youtube et c'est aussi à ça que
sert l'enseignement c'est former
l'esprit critique des ados et de ses
futurs habitants faire de futurs
citoyens et
du coup j'ai pas d'excès de m'en passer
parce que j'ai vu votre main ok ben
voilà c'est dit qu'il faut passer le
micro du goût voilà du coup de melbourne
est dans ton cas tu étais là il retenait
pas d'autant mieux tes vidéos que tu
étais le prof était aussi le vidéaste et
que du coup ça va ça il est marqué plus
que s'ils regardaient la vidéo de nattes
qui serait pas là c'est vrai que c'est
un cas qui arrivé plusieurs fois dans
mes classes que je suis devenu une star
depuis qu'ils savent que je fais des
vidéos voilà c'est un prof sur youtube
bon dieu et du coup quelqu'un qui
n'aimait pas la base c'est vraiment ça
c'est vraiment il ya un élève comme ça
ça m'a marqué c'était l'année dernière
il me détestaient je le détestais aussi
mais bon non mais voilà servis voit
malheureusement contre quelqu'un qu'on
apprécie pas ne sais pas pourquoi mais
c'est réciproque sur la sexe ça arrive
c'est épidermique je sais pas si ça se
dit mais voilà ça arrive malheureusement
de ne pas aimer une personne et c'est
réciproque et du jour au lendemain il a
découvert choisi des vidéos et et vous
d'humour tout les soutes tout à fait à
la fin de chaque cours à mon bureau pour
dire à ce que vous avez fait tout et du
coup juste sa note sa moyenne est passée
de 4 à 15
voilà juste parce que parce que je suis
le vidéaste et que son regard envers moi
a changé parce que voilà le prof c'est
le mec qui détient le savoir
c'est lui qui m'apporte la connaissance
ultime alors que le vidéaste un peu un
pote c'est pour ça qu'on a quasiment
tous des t-shirts et très peu souvent de
chemise finalement ce qui m'était
chemise la baraque ce lot pendant vos le
youtube heures c'est un pote est juste
aussi cette façon de se positionner par
rapport à celui qui est pas regarder la
vidéo ça change tout désolé je parle
beaucoup maintenant
tu dis c'est un pote mais c'est pas
aussi celui qui détient de savoir ton
avis enfin quelle est la posture du
vidéaste par rapport à celui du prof
toi qui as les deux casquettes du coup
je vais très bien je compliqué imposture
de vidéastes par rapport à celle du prof
tu mélange les deux ou pas vraiment
quand il remplace ta casquette de
professeur
l'aed proche une pièce de théâtre à
toute façon c'est fort c'est un rôle qui
se joue et tous les jours des fois j'en
gueule des gamins mais dans ma tête je
rigole parce qu'il faut les engueuler
des fois parce que tu des pertes sur mon
cours même si c'était drôle maintenant
désolé mais bon c'est pas c'était pas la
question
[Musique]
donc je suis moins exigeants envers ma
caméra mais non non parce que l'aveyron
veux dire c'est la vulgarisation quand
il arrive que ce soit dans mon métier ou
devant la caméra mais on va dire que le
niveau n'est pas le même que quand je
m'adresse en classe de 6e c
c'est quand même très simple un placer
les cinq massifs montagneux français ça
j'ai pas faire ça devant ma caméra
on va dire que juste pour concentrer les
sixièmes sais quel âge oui pardon ils
savent optique ses dix ans en dix ans
c'est le début du collège en france
juste après le prime
voilà sais pas si j'ai répondu je suis
sûr par contre que si j'étais si je te
rappeler ce que je travaille pas aux
lycéens dans les lycées c'est le plus
grand juste avant le bac à l'horaire
donc en belgique je sais pas comment ça
s'appelle d'accord si je suis sûr que si
je travaille au lycée sa place à
seulement dix courses est sensiblement
le même
entre le lycée et les vidéos voilà parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de lycéens du cou qui
vient de regarder les vidéos de la
chaîne
ils ont pris le micro parce que vu ni
pour ça va être transmis retransmission
live youtube normalement question mais
que bien avant le match en lui même est
en fait vous dit
le youtube heures c'est comme un pote
entre guillemets mais il ya quand même
des tueurs qui sont qui sont vachement
très propre action professionnelle en
fait qui sont limite froid quand il
parle avec eux des noms là maintenant ah
bah ouais je trouve que les rôles seront
là je trouve qu'à l'échelle scientifique
kahn sont vachement professionnel quand
il parle en fait et ils ont moins un
rapport que wayne on y voit là les
youtuber qui font du gué nourriture qui
font du gaming sont vachement proche
d'eux alors de leur communauté que que
le tueur avait de ça dépend un peu du
sujet j'aimerais je peux avoir votre
ressenti vous qui faites pas vous
décrire et de l'argent j'admire et votre
score de 6/7 valentino ou wii ou l'ordre
comme a par ailleurs entendu mon
ressenti
est-ce qu'on n'est pas trop finalement
des professionnels n'est pas la question
moi je crois qu'on soit sérieux j'ai
peur je pense que justement on essaie de
ne pas être sérieux
on s'en serait chiant si on était
sérieux sérieux moi je pense que je
tapote voilà votre sujet bah oui il faut
le des séries a lié le rendre moins en
moins compliqué moins sérieux parce que
ce soit plus accessible aussi wells et
soient plus simples trop sa pote tu vas
déjà il ya plusieurs écoles en sciences
il ya ceux qui aiment les vidéos qui
ressemblent à des cours et qui du coup
font des vidéos qui ressemblent à des
cours donc ça évidemment il ya enfin
comme tu dis il ya une distance vraiment
qui est créé et c'est voulu
et il y en a d'autres comme je sais pas
si tu regardes dirty biology bon ben
regarde le je pense que là au contraire
ils cassent complètement cette distance
qui peut y avoir entre celui qui raconte
les choses et celui qui les écoutent et
enfin c'est vraiment deux approches
différentes et il ya aussi un bien
vincent sous ben on a un message à faire
passer on a un contenu à faire passer
c'est quand même des faits d c'est pas
facile de trouver justement l'équilibré
entre la déconne on est potes et quand
même faut que tu apprennes des trucs
faut jongler wii.com tibet a dit ça
dépend vraiment du sujet pardon je vais
pas parler du génocide arménien en
rigolant le feu c'est drôle 50 milliards
voilà c'est s'adapter au sujet
concernant ma chaîne mais j'ai pas mal
de vidéos justement je parle de guerre
de bataille etc
c'est vrai que il faut adapter son
humour par rapport à ça c'est clair que
la vidéo de darty bayal et il serait
vagin l'eau ça peut être drôle ça dépend
vraiment du sujet donc mon histoire
malheureusement sa liste l'être humain
n'y a pas beaucoup de le sujet très très
heureux sauf la dernière et c'était
drôle avec le le trou du cul du 14
c'était drôle
d'autres réflexions
après moi je pense que c'est la
plateforme déjà qu'ils procurent un peu
ça tu auras genre côté prof tu es sur
youtube forcément il ya un petit côté un
peu un peu glamour je pense à dans
lequel deux bâtiments c'est vraiment la
plateforme ce qu'est la plateforme à la
base était surtout une plateforme pour
les gamer pour les humoristes s'étaient
la vulgarisation est allé vers un peu
tard et donc l'aura de youtube c'était
d'être justement un truc de mecs j'avais
branger est ce qu'on n'est pas forcément
puisque ya des vulgarisateurs en chemise
[Rires]
ou non mais t'es comme ce que c'est mais
il ya un côté moi je porte des chemises
était
et ne pas justement pour le côté un peu
prof j'ai parfois un ton très sérieux
c'est pas parce que je je en fait quand
on se dit qu'on retient pas forcément je
considère qu'on retient impasse il
commence à te donner des dates des
chronologies extrêmement précises en
histoire de l'art moi je considère que à
moins que tu sois étudiant en histoire
de l'art en train de prendre des notes
c'est pas ça que tu vas revenir d'une de
mes vidéos
par contre ce que je pense qu'on retient
c'est une idée générale non pour moi
quand j'écris une vidéo le principal
c'est qu'elle est qu'est-ce que qu'est
née l'idée générale que j'essaie de
transmettre par rapport à tel courant
artistique par rapport à tel artiste par
rapport à soi rose parce que ça par
contre effectivement je suis intimement
persuadé que si la démonstration est
intéressante la personne va revenir non
seulement l'idée mais potentiellement
même la démonstration est par contre
c'est ça que j'ai c'est beaucoup de
terre je suis pas certaine que pour le
coup le support vidéo te permettre de
revenir du détail peut t'aider à venir
de l'anecdote par contre nota bene la
très très bien prouver l'anecdote comme
c'est l'histoire racontée ça marche très
très bien la gêne de manon reid qui
raconte des épisodes de la mythologie
pareil comme c'est de l'histoire on
retient assez bien donc c'est des
histoires qu'on raconte
je suis pas sûr effectivement que et
mails mais même je pense donc là c'est
malheureusement c'est un truc tu ne me
contredira mais il sait pas évident de
faire venir des dates quoi un objet de
les marches l'air d'être au dieu voilà
ces personnes envie de retenir des dates
personne n'a envie de retenir parker
quelles sont les dates du surréalisme
n'importe quoi donc du coup c'est des
trucs en tant que prof on est beaucoup
plus obligés de marteler et les trucs un
peu jean marc teulié dans la vidéo
youtube
ainsi toutes les deux minutes dans la
vidéo je te rappelle avec l'invention de
la photographie 7839 tu vas quitter la
vidéo sur leurs amarres et donc c'est le
truc en batik aussi on est là on essaie
d'accrocher les gens et c'est pour ça
que moi j'ai plus la vidéo youtube com
soit un objet d'introduction qui donne
envie de s'intéresser au sujet soit un
objet qui sert à transmettre des grandes
idées et une manière de penser plus que
comme un truc où je vais transmettre du
fesf actuelle après c'est moi c'est ma
vision du truc je dis pas que c'est la
bonne mais je sais que c'est la même
chose en moi en tant que moi en tant que
consommatrice de vidéos ça me le faire
l'autre jour quand j'essayais
d'expliquer à mes parents le contenu
d'une vidéo justement du fameux dirty
biology en plus une des vidéos que je
préfère de lui qui s'appelle les enfants
artificielle et je la trouve géniale
j'ai vu plusieurs fois et je me rendais
compte que je n'avais pas leur expliquer
ce qui veut dire que malgré tout parce
qu'il a des paroles très rapide qui a
plein d'image c'est rigolo c'est très
fan ça fait j'ai envie de l'avoir
plusieurs fois par contre et ça c'est
génial mais malgré tout il ya un moment
une partie de l'info elle n'est pas
restée alors peut-être de tat en partie
à cause de moi parce que je suis une
énorme littéraire qui effectivement vite
rien à la science
mais malgré tout il y avait une
problématique de ce qui rend le format
youtube attractif qui fait que ce qui
rend moins attractifs peut parfois être
au détriment de l'information et je
pense que c'est ce dont on devra se
méfier quand on fait la vulgarisation
sur youtube il ya pour moi il ya deux
dont j'ai c'est soit être quad moins
accessible on est trop pointu dans son
domaine et on va tout faire les gens
soient faire de la sueur simplification
sait on prend un complexe à un concept
compliqué et on lui retire sa complexité
alors en fait le but est d'expliquer la
complexité du problème et le truc
effectivement par contre c'est qu'on est
tous un peu confronté à ça si tu veux un
minimum à diochon que tu fasses en tout
quatre actifs et c'est là qu'il faut se
méfier on n'a pas franchement le choix
afin de laisser parler lentement dans
mes vidéos ça marche très bien
noah welch et intercités avait un truc
ajouté patti survient le contredire s'il
te plaît non c'est parce que je suis
prof que je comptais du tournoi mais non
mon coeur mais c'est tellement plus
sympa quand les gens sont pas d'accord
entre eux parce que parce que ça nous
fait pas chier pendant je voudrais bien
parler de quelque chose dans votre vidéo
mais vous dites que ça va pas attirer
les gens forcément qui s'applique aussi
potentiellement j'aurai affaire teaser
de la vidéo parce que des intérêts
c'est si c'est clair et on s'éloigne un
peu du sujet et du coup enjoint la
confiance qu'on avait de l'autre côté il
ya quelques minutes c'était oui
clairement si on pour s'auto censure si
on pense qu'un sujet va pas intéresser
va pâtir il clique finalement on va
tirer le viewer tout cas la plupart des
gens voient pas le fait c'est si je
parle de la reproduction au sein des
oursins dans la mer méditerranée
ça va être compliqué at-il région dessus
donc oui évidemment ouais on
on avait personnellement avant de
commencer une vidéo donc si je vois car
sujet m'intéresse moi c est ce qu il va
intéresser les autres donc est 6e
après réflexion même après rédaction
d'un brouillon si je vois que finalement
ça ça va pas intéresser les gens dont je
les ferai pas donc c'est du langage et
durent laisser tomber pas mal de vidéos
comme ça après c'est aussi une histoire
de coups de génie que tu peux avoir
comme ça parce que tous les sujets
peuvent paraître plus ou moins
compliquées et des sujets par voie en
sciences par exemple tu prends les
matchs tu prends la physique c'est des
trucs sont quand même vachement ardue a
expliqué et pourtant c'est des chaînes
qui marche très bien tu as des chaînes
de maths comme big mat par exemple il
exclut que le principe des tables de
multiplication comment elles sont
arrivés ils expliquent plein de trucs de
géométrie fin des fois ils partent très
très loin dans les explications
et quand même ça marche étaient captivés
c'est juste une histoire de trouver la
bonne façon d'attraper le sujet et et
c'est aussi tout un art en fait je
voulais devenir une question
personnellement moi je je fais une vidéo
si elle me plaît même si en fait elle
n'est pas très vieux ça me dérange pas
récemment j'ai fait une vidéo sur la
première galerie spam en france parce
que j'ai trouvé son parcours fascinant
et je savais très bien qu'on intitulant
ma vidéo berthe weill personnes savaient
qu'ils s'étaient personnel et cliquer
dessus que le sujet l'intéressé très peu
de monde
elle est très peu vu et ça me dérange
absolument pas c'est moi personnellement
je fais de la vidéo avant tout pour moi
et ma chaîne pour moi c'est mon univers
personnel aussi donc c'est pas très
grave pour moi que les gens aient pas vu
cette vidéo je me suis j'ai prennent en
général plaisir à l'avoir fait le fait
de l'avoir fait en plus ma m'a aidé à
mieux comprendre sa femme à mieux
comprendre son parcours un mieux
comprendre même du coup le monde de
l'art en france
c'est con mais d'un tout petit truc
comme ça de la vie d'une personne j'ai
compris énormément de choses et en plus
je me suis amusé dans la dans la forme
aussi à faire un truc différent donc non
personnellement l'idée que ça plaise pas
aux gens c'est pas grave parce que même
si c'est comme si je fais lui sans lui
je me dis pas ce parapluie 100 personnes
ont entendu au moins une fois dans cette
personne de cette femme que je trouve
remarquable et moi personnellement ça me
suffit mais après c'est encore
c'est propre à chacun je pense qu'il ya
autant de manière de vulgariser kabyle
créateurs et on a tous une approche très
différente de hasard et peut-être que si
je travaille à 50 heures par semaine je
me suis dit ouh là berthevas elle
désolée j'ai pas le transfert un sujet
plus vendeur j'avais le temps dont je
les fait mais ça a vraiment c'est c'est
chacun qui voit midi à sa porte et quoi
il ya aussi peut-être aussi le facteur
je parle beaucoup
le facteur est ce que tu vives des
vidéos ou part parce que ça peut être
déterminé aussi le choix de sujets de
alors qu'il fait un blog récemment qui
s'appelle avoir un rapport sain et
youtube jeudi justement c'est c'est pour
ça que ce que je dis je ne porte aucun
jugement sur les gens qui choisissent de
faire des sujets parce qu'ils vont
marcher parce que moi j'ai la chance de
pas vivre de mes vidéos moi c'est par un
problème que ma vidéo alpha suisse en
vue ça me pose c'est rien c'est pas
grave c'est c'est juste bon bâton qui
j'ai travaillé sur un truc qui n'a pas
très bien marché mais ça ça arrive
toujours ma vie les gens qui vivent de
leur vidéo bien sûr c'est catastrophique
si elle fait pas fait pas beaucoup il
faut toujours tenir compte de ce à quoi
qui est la personne derrière la vidéo et
ça on le sait pas forcément mais il ya
des motivations et c'est pas ça
notamment que dans cette vidéo
j'explique que c'est ridicule de bâches
et un vidéaste parce qu'ils emploient ce
qu'on appelle le pit à clic c'est-à-dire
faire un titre ou à voir ensuite vidéo
très racoleur
il ya des bidasses qui font ça parce
qu'ils ont deux ans que la vidéo soit
vue pour vivre moi je m'en fiche vierge
heureusement que j'ai pas de mes vidéos
je suis nul contre des titres racoleurs
donc
oui bien sûr bien sûr que ça c'est hyper
important de se souvenir pourquoi on a
fait ça
moi je fais ça avant tout parce que ça
me plaît et j'essaye de transmettre
quelque chose aux gens que j'essaie de
transmettre ma passion pour l'art aux
gens ça s'arrête là je ne considère pas
comme étant enseignante sur youtube du
tout et je ne dis pas de mes vidéos
c'est vraiment juste juste une passion
donc et bien ok une question est donc on
parle de cette complémentarité entre
donc youtube et le monde de
l'enseignement
avec un titre un peu provocant de
va-t-il remplacer les manuels scolaires
donc on a parlé de deux éléments je
trouve très intéressant qui était la
posture et la distance par rapport à
comment le public justement on peut donc
être captées avoir de l'attention ce
qu'il retient et donc forcément on fait
quand même référence à votre capacité de
pédagogue
en tout cas je le sous-entend derrière
comment est ce que vous vous je veux
dire vous vous formez en tout cas vous
renforcer cette capacité donc à
vulgariser aux grandes le sujet le plus
pédagogiquement possible je veux dire
transmissibles a enfin à l'ailé vos jeux
etc
s'il te plaît alors moi je parlais du
coup par rapport à mon expérience
il ya beaucoup de profs qui m'ont
contacté pour me dire qu'ils se disaient
mes vidéos en cours du coup en
introduction quand est ce qu'on disait
c'est ta trousse iga tribune en panne
quasiment 90% c'est au québec au québec
moi ça se passe et j'ai même reçu des
commentaires des gens qui me disent dès
mon prof m'a dit de faire un exposé sur
la vidéo mais il ya aussi des gens qui
me disent j'ai rien compris
du coup les après un commentaire tout pc
d'expliquer et du coup tu essaies de
voir où tout a foiré d'un ton ou ta pas
été assez claire vois ce que tu allais
trouve était en fait dans les cours -
c'est avec l'aide des commentaires que
tu arrives à être plus clair genre la
photo est pas resté assez longtemps ces
changements m pause tu dis ça mais
pourquoi parce que ça paraît évident
pour toi mais ça l'est pas et ça permet
de mieux structurer au fur et à mesure
en dehors des vidéos d'avoir des vidéos
plus adapté et plus pédagogue
ouais j'suis d'accord les commentaires
ça aide énormément
le retour des gens et par important
alors malheureusement contrairement à ce
qu'on peut voir dans une salle de classe
pesd direct mais moi il ya un autre truc
en fait c'est je fais du jeu de rôle en
fait je me crée un personnage et mon
personnage que des liens à l'histoire de
l'art donc faut que j'écrive montech
sans me disant j'imagine que je en train
de m'adresser à ce personnage qui n'y
connaît rien et la moindre notion que
j'aborde que la personne peut ne pas
connaître ça c'est faux que l'expliquent
ou alors faut que je trouve un moyen de
parler du truc sans parler c'est une
notion si j'ai pas le temps donc
après il ya deux étapes d'une pierre
l'étape on fait les recherches ont écrit
texte ou d'un mois j'essaie toujours de
me dire je m'adresse à quelqu'un qui le
connaît bien et j'essaie vraiment être
d'être dans sa peau et il ya la phase de
montage qui une autre phase d'écriture
et c'est souvent le moment où moi je me
rends compte qu'il ya effectivement
c'est pas très claires et laure l'appui
visuel et c'est vraiment la force de
faire de la vidéo sur youtube c'est
qu'on a cette capacité d'illustrations
qui est hyper précieuse en tout cas dans
le champ de l'art mais je pense en tous
les gens dont on parle aujourd'hui et au
nom du montage on peut se rendre compte
qu'il ya des trucs qui sont pas claires
et la lette visuel on peut vraiment
mettre le paquet sur les visuels et ben
moi en l'occurrence g
j'ai une mémoire très visuel en plus
donc je fonctionne beaucoup à l'image et
donc quand j'écris les textes je pense
aussi déjà un petit peu à l'image mais
abbas et ça c'est juste partir du
principe qu'on ne ne sait rien johnston
ya peut-être d'autres réactions autre
question vas-y tu as ta question juste à
propos de la vulgarisation
je pense que c'est très important aussi
de regarder ce qui se fait à droite à
gauche et dans son domaine et dans
d'autres domaines et d'essayer dé
toucher un peu de voir ce qui nous a plu
ce qui nous a pas plu dans les vidéos
mais aussi dans les articles de blogs
dans les livres dans les émissions télé
fait un peu tout et de se faire comme ça
un petit catalogue de petites astuces
pour faire ça et je fais partie d'un
collectif qui s'appelle le collectif
conscience et on a mis en ligne un guide
de vulgarisation gratuitement avec plein
de petits conseils comme ça pour
vulgariser au mieux voilà tout juste
fait un petit peu du coup en fait moi je
resterai j'apprends pas parce que toi et
marthe vous avez 10 et c'est vrai que
pour vulgariser c'est pas un exercice
facile finalement fin du cours des
dégoûts chine appelle ça la
transposition didactique vocabulaire
donc transpo de transposer
didactiquement c'est rendre un contenu
complexe compréhensible et non pas
justement en vue la complexité du
problème comme disait sartre et voit
justement j'ai adopté la même attitude
que connacht c'est vraiment que ce soit
qu'on m'écoute pour pour les vidéos
c'est partir du constat que par la syrie
aujourd'hui c'était compréhension et
qu'il faut expliquer comment ça
fonctionne et en fait avant même de
tourner ma vidéo je fais lire mon script
à plusieurs personnes et si s'ils n'ont
pas de question à la fin c'est que j'ai
réussi
l'importance de l'écriture
ah oui
je voulais poser des questions tiens
justement à la formation de professeurs
étaient reçus en france est-ce que ça
doit être un bon bus ou c'est trop carré
où il faut apprendre à côté aussi pour
faire s'adapter au public de l'étude
d'attendre et la formation de profs en
france allait bien pour être prof en
france il faut que tu fasses trois
années déjà d'études sur la matière que
tu as envie d'enseigner donc en
l'occurrence histoire là il n'y a pas de
pédagogie pas de petit à petit rien
c'est juste l'histoire histoire histoire
qui peut de géo histoire histoire
histoire géopolitique
donc quand on te demande d'être
wikipedia en mieux donc ça c'est la
licence après talent master donc si tu
as beaucoup de profs qui ont fait un
master dont six dans la matière qu'ils
enseignent dans mon cas ça aurait été
master histoire master que j'ai mais en
fait pile au moment où je passais le
master histoire il ya le masters
enseignement qui venait de créer sache
tout s'aggrave que le master
enseignement certains des études qui
nous forme est enseignant n'est commencé
à exister en france qu'en 2012
deux minutes ouais 2011 2012 avant il y
avait rien enfin il y avait du cabinet
licence je sais plus comment s'appelait
mais c'était pas vraiment destiné à
l'enseignement donc en fait avant il
suffisait d'être un spécialiste en la
matière tu peux être prof
mais ceux qui restent spécialiste en la
matière c'est souvent les plus mauvais
profs du monde parce que justement ils
savent pas faire cet exercice de
transposition didactique ou te justement
de vulgarisation d'un savoir et ça se
voit même encore aujourd'hui il y en a
qui y font parce que c'est le masters
enseignement n'est pas obligatoire on
peut faire un dock master et
ceux qui savent pas se mettre au niveau
des élèves c'est horrible c'est horrible
c'est en temps quelqu'un qui parle avec
un vocabulaire l'ultra haut perchée très
spécifique comprend moins deux mois pour
sunrise et j'ai du mal à comprendre
certains collègues quand il parle
est ce qu'ils sont ils sont tellement
ils ont tellement savoir ils sont
contents de le transmettre
mais du coup ils transmettent rien du
tout parce qu'ils savent pas la
transmettre correctement voilà et donc
ce qui peut aider oui bah du coup c'est
le nouveau master enseignement qui
existe maintenant et kiwi la dispo
propose des formations à la pédagogie la
didactique
par contre ce master manque cruellement
de tests sur le terrain parce que
souvent les nouveaux profs c'est on les
lâche dans la fosse aux lions opine-t-il
dit merde voilà
mais du coup oui je trouve que du coup
ce master enseignement m'a aidé à
vulgariser comme scénario s'il attire le
design art et je te contrit pas beaucoup
je répète beaucoup de choses que tu as
lu j'étais un des fils de ma pensée
encore c'est samedi d'habitude samedi
trahi la formation d'enseignants
oui oui et puis de est justement quand
j'utilise un terme bien spécifiques par
exemple héliotropisme géographie je peux
pas leur dire juste comme ça mon
héliotropisme il faut que je montre une
carte de france et qui est leur montrer
mais ils le savent
l'autre piste c'est juste qu'ils savent
pas mettre le mode dessus le mot dessus
peindre c'est le fait que les
populations soient tirées par un climat
plus agréable c'est ce qui fait que le
sud de la france est repartie attractif
mais ça hurle ça tout le monde le sait
en tout cas les français désolé que le
site de la france est plus attractif que
que pardon voilà où que la champagne
ardenne par exemple voilà c'est parce
qu'il est plus agréable
après les moeurs ça c'est autre chose et
ici à des enseignes homme y est la règle
alors il ya des enseignants aussi vous
utilisez peut-être des vidéos d'un
recours est-ce que c'est des choses
c'est une pratique qui est courante chez
vous ou que vous voulez installer un
petit oui voilà c'est pas sorcier c'est
trop bien c'est trop bien fait c'est pas
que j'aime pas les sens mais je peux
rien j'ai vraiment une formation
littéraire et je trouve ça
extraordinaire c'est pas sorcier enfin
c'est très bien vite arrivé et ce que je
trouve super bien pour les plus jeunes 6
et les dessins animés
la vie je passe le connaissez on à
l'intérieur du corps humain et à ça moi
franchement ça m'a tellement aidé quand
j'étais petite à comprendre et là par
mois je
en ce moment on est en train de me
rediriger professionnellement je te
renseigner à des petits et je pense
vraiment que des vidéos comme la vie
c'est un truc c'est extraordinaire et
c'est beaucoup mieux de leur expliquer
enfin de leur montrer une vidéo comme ça
ce sera ça va beaucoup plus les marques
et que si on leur explique voilà les
globules rouges qui transportent
l'oxygène mais il faut des petits
personnages avec leurs petites bulles
d'oxygène et tout de suite j'ai pas le
support visuel et tout va tellement on
s'en servait tellement les aider à
comprendre pour moi c'est c'est ceux qui
sont remarquables et que malheureusement
enfants il ya des vidéastes c'est très
très dur sur internet je dis pas mais
aucun de nous les budgets de faire ce
genre de truc mais c'est
des choses remarquables qui sont faites
et je crois qu'effectivement le la
valeur ajoutée et quand vous vous
contredisez de youtube heures pour les
peut-être un peu plus âgés que pas des
tout petits mais c'est c'est justement
l'aura de la plateforme youtube
c'est le côté c'est un pote c'est moi il
est comme moi je crois qu'il ya vraiment
il ya vraiment ça qui joue et qui fait
que je pense que quelqu'un comme darty
baloji énormément de jeunes le regarde
avec beaucoup de beaucoup de plaisir
parce qu'ils ont l'impression que c'est
un mec exactement comme eux très jeune
qui aime des trucs crado c'est rigolo
voilà et et je pense que c'est vraiment
ça éventuellement et c'est pour ça qu'à
la rigueur je trouve que plus encore que
la diffusion en classe moi ce que je
trouve vraiment cool avec youtube ce
serait effectivement la diffusion avant
la classe le soir en devoir de trucs
comme ça je pense que c'est vraiment
génial si un jour voilà en fait un sujet
en sciences communiste avait des gens
très très doué n'hésitez pas c'est à
dire et aux élèves d'aller voir une
vidéo pour introduire le sujet vachement
ça peut être ça peut être moins bonne
idée et abonnez vous et il ya encore un
autre usage de youtube
donc c'est un autre usage de youtube
dans l'enseignement dont on n'a pas
parlé ce serait éventuellement de de
faire faire des vidéos aux élèves et ça
j'ai un ami qui s'appelle pierre karner
qui est le fondateur de la plate forme
vidéo science c'est un collectif de
vidéastes scientifique qui fait ça en
fait il a co créé avec un ami des cours
pour apprendre à ses élèves au niveau
fac à vulgariser des sciences ou qu'ils
ont un sujet imposé ils doivent en faire
un article de blog une vidéo youtube et
une présentation et une présentation
style vraiment ça part dans tous les
sens la dernière c'était hier et
quelques semaines et il avait des
costumes de requins pour raconter enfin
voilà ça partait dans tous les sens et
c'était très drôle et franchement les
élèves en ont retiré enfin les étudiants
en ont retiré un vrai plaisir de faire
ça il s'est investi mais beaucoup plus
que si on leur avait juste appris la
même chose
temps et voilà la puissance de youtube
et en plus la fierté de pouvoir montrer
leurs vidéos après à leurs potes et doug
et moi je trouve que c'est vraiment un
truc qu'on devrait développer plus
encore ce truc c'est vraiment un super
idée façon c'est les enseignants qui
sont dans la salle pour confirmer dès
qu'on les aime on demande aux élèves de
s'investir dans un projet souvent ils
sont à fond puis beaucoup nous est passé
c'est impressionnant
par exemple que sa reynard vrai que la
vidéo mais justement montré que les
élèves peuvent s'investir et au delà de
presque de l'imaginaire c'est j'ai
travaillé régime de vichy l'a récemment
avec les 3e et je leur ai demandé de
faire un tract de danty propagande
contre le régime de vichy le régime du
coup en asie et yann à caraman qui sont
avec la tablette graphique on me sortir
des tracts j'ai eu des travaux
vraiment impressionnant de même d'élèves
qui d'habitude je crois si je suis ton
cours parce qu'il faut que ce soit alors
qu'elle a dû coûter souvent dès qu'on
demande aux élèves d'où l'idée de
s'investir s'adonne que du bonheur et du
bien et du coup ce que tu dis c'est bien
mais vraiment su rester à terre c'est
quasiment impossible dans le secondaire
geste à cause des infrastructures moi je
suis désolé je suis dans deux
établissements les deux établissements
c'est limite on vient de passer aux
écrans plats sains les cantates écran
cathodique sens car la religion
majoritaire dans l'établissement et donc
à voir c'est ça c'est ça c'est saison on
a tous les profs ont d'excellentes idées
franchement si on appliquer l'idée que
la pour les profs on dirait très très
loin mais lors de l'ennui c'est que
c'est pas le lieu du mot n'est là c'est
la monnaie tout court donc
vous êtes malheureusement c'est
extrêmement compliqué je pense que les
preuves qui sont ici peuvent confirmer
la majeure partie des établissements
niveau technique c'est encore windows xp
windows xp un sou vent qui n'est plus
mis à jour depuis longtemps donc
d'ailleurs enfin de problème juste il ya
tout ce qui est droit à l'image aussi
avec les wiener la sefa les gens majeurs
donc ça va mais effectivement des
mineurs sur youtube
non justement personnellement je forme
suis formateur this en france je vendais
des futurs profs pour justement dans
l'exercice de leur métier et gestion
normale je leur montre lescun preuve peu
risqué juste à mettre la photo d'un
élève sur son espace perso tarn sur
icloud ou je sais pas quelle autre
dropbox
juste ça ça peut être dix mille euros
damende par exemple c'est il ya beaucoup
de profs qu'il offre ou même juste
mettre le nom d'un élève avec son prénom
dans une arène fichier excel puisqu'on
volontiers à une trace des notes basses
et puni par la loi normalement on fait
tous parce que merde par les profs pour
montrer aux élèves mais c'est pas
forcément pour leur apprendre un truc
c'est peut-être juste pour le plaisir un
moment qu'il ya une bosse de quoi et
vraiment je sais pas si c'est pareil en
france parce que ça fait longtemps que
je me suis fait à l'école mais en
angleterre où c'est omniprésent la vidéo
là bas pas du tout bon
enfin la vidéo est absolument pas
omniprésente en france enfin du coup moi
je considère vraiment la vidéo comme
l'outil est pas comme quelque chose qui
va remplacer le prof donc du coup je
contredisait personnes ces choses j'ai
apporté un complément une question
comment justement la question était
justement par broc au monde de
l'enseignement est ce que le fait de
passer pour les canaris youtube c'est
quelque chose de plus porteur que de
créer soi même son petit site internet
ou son blog où ses propres vidéos et de
naviguer à côté de youtube l'important
n'est malheureusement pas assisté à la
table ronde qui a eu sur les plateformes
alternatives
mais à l'heure actuelle c'est sûr que
c'est très très difficile d'avoir de la
visibilité en dehors de youtube pendant
fait de la vidéo c'est vraiment le canal
de diffusion majoritaire il écrase tout
le reste est pour l'instant il n'y a
rien qui arrive encore à détrôner
après c'est évident que youtube a aussi
des pose pas mal de problèmes éthiques
et autres donc si quelqu'un ici songe à
faire des vidéos et n'est pas d'accord
avec la politique de youtube notamment
la publicité si je crois mais des
classes aux médias mais déclassé un site
aussi voilà par exemple pour des
enseignants pour des gens qui veulent
faire de la vulgarisation il s'appelle
médias classe effectivement et où des
gens qui essayent de créer des
plateformes alternatives effectivement
youtube pose quand même voilà mais c'est
payant des classes parce que le problème
c'est que van liew tube ça peut être
gratuit
parce que c'est un monstre parce que c'
est rattachée à google est passé des
serveurs gigantesque et que à l'échelle
d'une médias classe a été créé par une
personne croit une personne tout cela ne
peut pas ne peut pas réussir à créer un
voile
un truc pour faire pour rivaliser
youtube mais mais voilà mais youtube à
pose de nombreux problèmes récemment ils
ont mis en place un mode restreint pour
justement si jamais vous avez des
enfants des jeunes enfants etc
youtube automatiquement cache un certain
nombre de vidéos et moi je trouve ça
très intéressant de voir quelle vidéo
étaient cachés sur ma chaîne est en fait
je sais que c'est un algorithme que du
tout va pas à voir vidéo par vidéo mais
il ya eu beaucoup de scandales notamment
toutes les vidéos avec du contenu lgbt
ont été masqués mois une vidéo je n'ai
absolument aucune idée pro-otan j'ai
fait une vidéo sur un réflexe je peux
très bien comprendre qu'on veut pas
exposer des enfants à ça or une vidéo
sur l'origine du monde je comprends très
bien l'origine du monde de courbet qu'on
n'ait pas envie que les enfants la
voient autant j'ai fait une vidéo belle
saison sa première femme galerie de
france et youtube a décidé que c'était
un contenu inapproprié pour les fans
voilà donc il ya beaucoup de trucs comme
ça avec youtube où on n'est pas
forcément d'accord la monétisation
vacances forcées des vidéos et tout
quand on utilise ne serait-ce que 30
secondes de musique on va il ya des
trucs avec youtube mais malheureusement
pour l'instant si on veut un minimum de
visibilité et a priori si on essaye de
mimiques et sa passion pour l'histoire
les sciences et là on a envie que ce
soit un minimum vue donc pour l'instant
moi en tout cas je connais pas ce qu un
terme at-il ça dépend du public visé
aussi parce que si jamais quelqu'un m'a
placé juste parce que je pense à une
autre alternative c'est l'e book mais du
coup c'est pas vraiment de vidéos
youtube c'est des lignes donc ces
massives open mind coccyx donc cédé des
cours en ligne qui sont gratuits et
ouverts à tous en france il ya une
grande plate forme c'est fun donc qui
porte très mal son nom
c'est france université numérique et
dessus on peut s'inscrire et accédez
gratuitement des cours en ligne qui sont
en vidéo est là effectivement c'est tout
l'inversé de ce que tu disais c'est
vraiment un prof qui te suit un cours
devant et la plupart du temps le montage
est dégueulasse la réalisation est
dégueulasse tout est nul mais mme et
apprendre des trucs donc il ya cette
alternative à youtube mais il ya un
autre problème c'est qu'il faut à être
inscrits pour voir les vidéos tu peux
pas les repartager après elles sont
disponibles que dans un très court laps
de temps enfin c'est pas du tout la même
chose que youtube
ah oui c'est vrai c'est compliqué de
passer outre youtube aujourd'hui après
comme dit valentine ça dépend vraiment
du public visé si vous aussi vous créez
une des vidéos pour vos élèves finale
youtube des pastilles obligatoire que ça
suffit de donner l'adresse url à vos
élèves et vous voilà même sur votre
dossier
en ligne dropbox ou qu importe
maintenant ils prennent les vidéos en
charge je suis partagé ce lien voilà
c'est assez simple prévoit là évidemment
si vous voulez vous faire connaître
youtube c'est obligatoire j'étais
youtube tellement il s'est tellement il
met hégémonique que c'est vous pouvez
pas passer outre
donc oui du coup il a justement je
connais une chaîne de ponzi
si elles étaient français ici une chaîne
de profs français qui qui font des
vidéos du coup de cours sur youtube ça
s'appelle les bons profs et
contrairement à ce que tu racontes et
notamment avec les fans
là c'est fait c'est franchement ce
qu'ils font c'est chouette ça et c'est
le court en tant que tel donc si mes
élèves veulent réviser par deep house va
regarder cette chaîne ne s'était pas
fait pour le court donc une vidéo de 5
minutes
il ya tout un chapitre et je trouve ça
vraiment pas mal donc s'il ya des
français ici vous invite à aller voir
c'est des bons profs
enfin quatre une dernière question la
restitution au lourd passé encore une
réflexion en question parmi vous oui non
très bien merci à vous en tout cas on
peut les applaudir
je veux dire aussi
c'est beau donc voilà la vidéo d'un
enseignement balle un outil de
vulgarisation un outil qui sert de
support date d'introduction à certains
sujets voilà un pas tellement
l'alternative donc voilà on vous invite
à aller consulter les chaînes des pertes
de youtube heures 6 est présent pour
peut-être les présenter dans vos classes
non merci beaucoup et il prouve la
petite fierté nationale juste dire que
c'est sandra kim qui chante le générique
de de la vie donc sandra kim qui a gagné
d'autres horizons pour la belgique en
1986 voilà c'était pour la petite
anecdote merci à vous et vos la suite
des événements